when the moon hits your eye like a big
pizza pie it's Andrew Cuomo and you're
listening to this fool like pasta fazool
is Chris Cuomo and the garlic knot tells
you you gotta stay inside and you listen
did you see the video of Chris Cuomo
it's on you had a beet coronavirus by
breathing cuz Chris Cuomo had
coronavirus and he's like a guy called
me cuz yo Chris gone was a tough guy
ain't gonna let the virus beat me I'm a
[ __ ] garlic knot so Chris Cuomo sees
like a pulmonologist called me and told
me he's like Chris you got that Corona
you gotta do it you gotta got up the
virus wants you in your bed
these guys a tough guy couldn't handle
the word frayed out the virus wants you
in your bed you got to get up and
breathe deep it's literally can we play
that yeah Chris Cuomo giving people
advice on data beat coronavirus by doing
some weird chest yoga which may help I
don't know but I mean I mean maybe he's
right maybe the pulmonologist is right I
just have a low opinion of the Cuomo
family he's like you gotta breathe you
gotta get the virus once you are here we
go this is it okay so here's what I've
learned here's the secret to kicking
this virus just a secret potion
it's about your a will he said by you
will devotion if the vibration wants us
to lay down the virus water lay down
naked are you a fan oke other than the
blessed few the rest of us who get this
are gonna have an experience unlike
anything else they've ever had days and
waves the old notion of getting bed and
stay there when you get sick it sounds
great and if you're really up against it
you need to do as little as possible I
love that this is all written why can't
anyone like I do it all the time why
can't you just talk like why can't he
speak like he's reading something that's
written clearly right why can't he just
sit talk cuz every speech is just
prepared for him in public right I mean
does he even
have Corona Vaculik are we these are
these people lying that like these
celebrities to say they have it they
really have it some of these people on
their instagrams are like you know man
it's been very hard for me did you like
this little coffee like you like is this
real did your agent call you and go hey
ah you gotta you gotta you gotta come
out that you got co fat 19 there are
agents calling people right now god
here's the best move for you right now
COFF COFF a lot on instagram live
because you need people need to follow
your kovat 19 journey so listen I'm
gonna play some of this because maybe
Chris Cuomo is right okay what you know
Bob Grant who is a phenomenal
conservative radio huh there's gonna be
a conservative show everybody we did a
we did a communist show last week we're
gonna oscillate we go fascist communist
every other week keep everybody happy
okay I don't know who's gonna win but
what I will whatever boot is on your
neck as to what I support so a Bob grant
whatever you think of his politics
you're racist whatever but a great you
know radio guy old-time radio guy used
to go get off my phone and people would
call him up they bill it Bob it's Pony
from Seaside Heights
it was always Tony from Seaside Heights
a long time list the first time caller
Bob what do you think about and they
they were just some [ __ ] he'd go you
know what Tony he do me a favor
you fake phony fraud that was just his
tag you know that was his you know
signature line he'd go you fake phony
fraud get off my phone and he kick him
off the phone he used to call the
Cuomo's father Mario Cuomo I think he
called them son of swatching now I don't
know what that means
it's probably bad but Bob Grant used to
make son of swatching all right P Bob
Grant Bob Grant got kicked off WABC
radio because when Ron Brown a Clinton
associate was killed in a plane crash
that's a shock someone near the Clintons
killed Bob Grant said something like the
only good news
coming out of this will be if we find
that Ron Brown is dead and he did die
and Bob grant was kicked off he was
kicked off ABC and then he went to wor
and I used to make my grandmother listen
to Bob grant while she would drive me
like to and from play practice and dance
class so that's how gay Republicans come
to be you go to dance class and you
listen to Bob grant and Rush Limbaugh on
the way I'm all gay people by the way
secretly Republican that's true all of
them every single one of them I'm dead
I'm joking about that somebody by the
way you want to talk about rotted brains
someone on Instagram accused me this is
great they go uh in your latest sketch
you say V of a wife and I'm like the
statues me playing a owner of a like a
developer who owns properties and I'm
evicting people and he goes with don't
you think that's saying a wife instead
of husband is like a little [ __ ] up
and I'm like the point of the sketch is
that I'm a demon from hell real estate
developer evicting nurses from the
building and and and kicking people to
the street and this is how identity
politics rots people's heads he's like
yeah but you said so I'm like so your
problem is that the demon real estate
developer isn't get you want him to be
gay in the sketch that's on Instagram
that's what you want let's let's
continue here with Chris Cuomo who does
not have coronavirus I know but you
can't stay there now I'm wise to the
Beast and it sways it changes
the fever is just softened by the way he
means by the way beast his ways he means
Jews that's what he means by that and
then they had to you know what him and
his brothers say behind closed doors you
know they're small-minded sauce monkeys
you know they are you know what they say
when they get a [ __ ] ball of sauce on
the table and they take a couple of
hunks of bread and dip it into the pot
of sauce you know they got a couple of
choice words
for who owns the media that again I'm
imagining that's what they do I have no
proof of that
that's something I'm imagining Chris and
his Neanderthal brother do cuz they're
Neanderthals you look at Andrew Cuomo's
face he's a Neanderthal he's in the end
Rafal andrew Cuomo Chris Cuomo is a
little you know whatever in your body
hurt so you don't want to move your body
because what it wants to do is get in
your lungs that's what it wants to do I
feel it constricting my chest when I had
that chest x-ray did I I saw that
infiltrate right away now I also have
something else I haven't told you I have
a low IgM level I've enjoyed the primary
I have something else I had it was a low
IQ in fact it was embarrassing for my
family to find out how low it was I'm
basically functionally [ __ ]
that's why I have to read a script right
now instead of just talking to you like
a normal person about my experiences
with coronavirus I have to read a
prepared statement because I'm genuinely
on the border of mental retardation and
I have a television show I genuinely
have a television show and cannot
process information like other people so
I have to have a prepared statement
about my sickness body I've always had a
low level okay it's not something recent
it could be genetic it could be cultural
I don't know but it makes me susceptible
to things like bronchitis and crap like
that so there I was on Friday night okay
I was not gonna do the show tonight I
was done I was in a pool of sweat 12
hours later I was in the same damn place
I hadn't slept a minute
I was just soaked and scared honest to
god so then I get a call from a friend
of a friend of a friend
now this keeps happening to me now this
new reality of how much people just care
I have this new network of not just
sources but really good people and they
all come this way friend of a friend of
a friend do you think your brothers do
you think Chris let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question here
do you think some of that network is cuz
your brother's too governor do you think
that
possibility I don't know do you think
that I'm not sure do you think it's cuz
you have a television show some people
you said that's just great network now
if people that truly care about me they
really care
keep going battling this all over the
country in the world and people want to
beat the beast so this doctor calls me
up
asked me about my symptoms he's a
pulmonary expert and says can you get up
I say yeah I can get up he says do it he
says can you stretch your torso I said
well how great was somebody pranking
Chris Cuomo like somebody just getting
them to do like how are you yes this is
Daniel Cohen I'm a pulmonary expert at
Langone I'm just calling you can you get
up right now can you stretch your torso
can you do you know the funky chicken
dance I want you to do that right now
and I know you're gonna laugh but I'm
gonna tell you right now the funky
chickens movements open up the
passageways in your lungs that get the
virus out so I want you to do that right
now and I want you to do it outside of
your house because it's you need the
fresh air can you do the running man can
you do the running man right now can you
let me tell you why the running man
increases circulation in such a way that
the virus is less able to bind to your
red blood cells can you do the running
man right now
can you put you a video of you doing the
running man on your Instagram account
right now can you do that let me ask you
another question and this is gonna seem
but you guys stick with me I'm the head
pulmonologist can you do blackface can
you do Plett me tell you why blackface
helps if you put blackface on your face
the virus gets scared because the virus
is racist you know the way Asians feel
about blacks the virus is very racist so
if you do blackface the virus doesn't
get in there do you see what I mean
you want to keep going yeah man we gotta
like this yeah no it doesn't feel that
good he said do it he said can you [ __ ]
I said probably not do it you [ __ ] do
it do it and then City
heard me saying I wanted to keep this
out of my lungs and he says raise its in
your lungs and you got the right fear
and you got the wrong approach
you can't wait it out he said you have
to fight I'm not in some silly
metaphorical way
this isn't about like channeling rocking
or eye of the tiger you've got to do the
things that will beat this virus you've
got to breathe deep when it hurts and it
hurts I know it hurts and I'm not trying
to minimize anybody's pain when you get
a fever spike and that hurts he said you
can't take confidence that it's gonna go
down they're gonna be spikes for at
least 10 days when you get a fever you
got a layer up you got a drink you got
it's amazing about this virus by the way
no and we're done with him but nobody
has any clue at all what's going on like
nobody has any like not a clue right no
but fever for ten day like what are we
saying here what are we talking about
what is going on nobody has a clue now
they said you read something says soap
doesn't do anything ventilators make it
worse doesn't kill the coronavirus yeah
yeah ventilators make it worse soon
they're gonna say hand sanitizer spreads
it like what do you